[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All right,
I'm going to get started.
This is lecture 14
of 14.13 The lecture
today is about attention.
OK.
Good.
So where are we
at in this class?
In this class, we talked a
lot about preferences so far.
Think about preference
describing in economics.
What do people want?
What makes them happy
in one way or the other?
We talked about time
preferences, risk preferences,
and social preferences,
time preferences.
How do people make
choices over time?
Risk preferences
are, how do people
deal with risky situations
when some things are uncertain
and others are more certain?
Or sometimes good things
happen, sometimes not.
And there's a probability
distribution over those events.
And how does that affect
how you make choices?
And social
preferences is what we
talked about during the
last few weeks, which
is how does the presence of
others affect our choices?
How much do we
care about others?
And do we decide or
make choices differently
if others are involved?
So now what we've
done with preferences
is sometimes saying
we have our models
to think of ways to think
about what makes people happy.
The second part when you
try to make decisions
is when you look at your
environment, what are prices
like?
What do we know about others?
What are our beliefs?
And what do we attend to?
And how do we learn when
we get new information?
So what information do we have?
And what information
do we attend to?
And how do we learn when we get
new information given to us?
And so we're going to
talk first about attention
in this lecture.
And then the next
couple of times, we're
going to talk about
beliefs and learning.
So what we're going
to do today is
we're going to talk
about three broad issues.
One is going to provide you
some motivating evidence
about attention.
We had a little bit on
this in lectures 1 and 2.
But I wanted to remind
you of that a little bit.
Then we're going to talk
about two specific papers.
One is a pretty famous
paper by Raj Chetty
and co-authors on
inattention to taxes.
And then you're going to talk
about a second paper, which
is learning by noticing.
In particular, we're going
to ask the question of,
how is it possible that people
do not attend to things that
are important in their lives?
You might say, well, if
attention is limited,
that's all good.
But then we should
expect that people attend
to really important stuff.
So some sort of rational
inattention models
would say, well, it
might well be that people
are inattentive in some ways.
But really, it can't be
possibly that the welfare
losses from
inattention are large
because if they were
large, if there's things
that people missed,
then they would
pay attention to those things
and shift their attention
optimally.
The learning by
noticing paper is
one theory, at
least potentially,
that addresses this question.
The way these movie perception
tests work is, essentially,
they look for what's
called change blindness.
So the way this works
is, often, there's
one actor, which
is this guy here.
I think you can see
probably right now there's
some guy who does some activity.
You're supposed
to watch the guy.
And then there's a second
scene in some ways where
the person does something else.
In this case, the guy--
sorry, where is he?
The guy is taking a phone call.
And so what happens then is--
essentially, then, this
guy that you see here
that takes a phone call is a
different person altogether.
And so that's called
change blindness
where, essentially,
people then tend
to not notice at
all that there's two
different people in a scene.
There's other types
of experiments
that do this, as well.
One version of that would
be people who go to a bank.
There's a bank teller.
And this is like all
psych experiments.
There's a bank teller.
Here's the other guy.
So you see this guy.
He looks actually very
different to the other guy
that you had seen before.
So people go to the bank.
There's a bank teller.
The bank teller
says, oh, yeah, I'll
have to just get
something from the back.
And then another
person shows up who's
a totally different person,
often looks very different,
sometimes wears
different things.
And people just
don't notice at all.
And that's sort of
type of experiment
is called change blindness.
I've already shown you
the gorilla test before.
I'm going to not play it again
because I've already seen it.
But essentially,
it's the same where
people are asked
to pay attention
to how many passes people
play in a basketball game.
And then there's a
guy who's in a gorilla
suit who shows up and walks
through the whole screen.
And many people just
miss the gorilla suit.
Now, what's going on here?
There is a large number of
these types of experiments.
They're called change blindness
or inattention experiments.
And there's another
version of that,
which is called the dichotic
listening experiment.
This is going back
to broadband, 1958.
They essentially look
something like this
where there's people who wear
headphones with messages.
On the one hand, on
our left, there's
supposed to be ignored inputs.
And on the other hand, there's
supposed to be attended inputs.
So the person in
the experiment is
asked, only listen to
stuff that's, I guess,
in your left ear.
These are the attended inputs.
I'm going to ask you some
questions about that.
And then what you're
supposed to then do is--
are you still stuck?
This is bad.
One second.
I'm going to unshare my screen.
Exactly.
Give me a second.
So the way this works is you
would have headphones on.
And on one hand, you
hear inputs that you're
supposed to attend to.
On the other ear,
you hear inputs
that you're not
supposed to attend to.
And usually, then, you
get explicit instructions
to attend to the
message in one ear
and then asked later about
message in the other ear.
People can't remember it.
And then what these
experiments often are--
when asked to keep a
number in their head,
people remember the
played message much less.
So essentially, what this
shows is that, A, I guess,
people are pretty good at
shifting attention in some way.
But attention is
limited to the extent
of when you're also supposed
to attend to something
else at the same time.
It's essentially
too much going on,
and it's really hard for
you to remember everything.
And so to some degree,
it tells us, A, I guess,
attention is limited.
We tend to focus--
when instructed,
at least, we tend
to focus on stuff
that's important, right?
So like in the
broadband experiment,
if I tell you listen to
the stuff in the right ear,
you actually focus
your attention
to the stuff in the right ear.
You miss the stuff
on the left ear,
so you can sort of direct
your attention to stuff
that you think is
important or you've
been instructed to focus on.
So that kind of works.
But at the same time, attention
is limited in the sense of you
can actually not remember
what's in the other ear
because you didn't attend to it.
So in some sense, it's
not like you automatically
remember stuff.
You have to pay
attention to things.
And then at the same time,
when we now exogenously reduce
people's attention
by telling people
to keep a number in their head,
distracting them in some way,
people are much more--
even playing the played
message, the message that you're
supposed to remember.
I'm sure they don't remember
the other message, either.
OK.
So then in addition, which
I already alluded to,
attention is limited.
There might be different
factors that might
affect people's attention.
So what factors might be
important for attention?
Could be your physical
environment in some ways.
It could be it's really hot.
It could be it's really cold.
It could be other
threats in the room,
so if you're in some
place where you're
worried that there will be wild
animals coming anytime soon.
Physical environment
could be really important.
It could be really loud.
Distractions could
be social media.
It could be other
stuff that you're just
trying to do at the same time.
Maybe you're trying to solve
some problems right now.
Maybe you're trying to prepare
for some-- for example,
I had a phone call
just before our class.
And I was also trying to think
about what to do in class,
and it's just really
distracting to have
other things you're thinking
about at the same time.
Could be worries about your
own or others' well being.
It could be sleep or what
people were saying already,
people's physical environment.
We're going to talk about some
of this in the poverty lecture.
So there in
particular, one thing
that poverty tends
to come along with
is sort of a bunch of
different ways of--
in addition to not having money
and many other deprivations,
poverty tends to come along
with lots of other factors
that might reduce
people's attention.
And that's to do with sleep.
It's to do with
exposure to noise.
It's coming with worries
about people's health
and so on and so forth.
There's some question
about practice.
Can you actually
practice attention?
And there's some
people who would
argue, at least in education,
maybe at younger ages--
suppose you sit
kids down and have
them practice focusing on
tasks like multiplications
or whatever and
do math problems.
Some of this, some
people would argue,
in addition to
just helping people
learn math, actually the numbers
and so on and how to multiply,
you might also
actually just help
students learn how to focus and
how to pay attention carefully
to things and particularly
sustained attention
and not get distracted
by other things.
Other distractions,
by the way, also,
like temptations, for example.
So if I put a delicious
chocolate cake in front of you
and have you-- and if
you're really hungry,
that might be
actually really hard
to pay attention
to whatever else
you're doing just because that's
really distracting to you.
OK.
And so we're going to,
for now, keep thinking
about attention being fixed.
We're going to get back
to the issue of attention
being malleable and
potentially being
depleted by issues such as
poverty at the end in the very
last lecture.
But for now, we're
going to look at--
think about attention
as fixed but limited.
And now we're going
to look at, what
are the consequences of that?
OK.
So then one question
you might ask
is, well, this listening
task that I just showed you
or when a monkey walks through
some video or the like,
it's a pretty
low-stakes situation.
Who really cares?
And one Chicago
view of economics
would be to say, well, these
are just low-stakes situations.
But once stakes are
really high, then people
will surely pay attention.
And so there's a number
of different papers
that look at this issue.
But one quite nice example
here is from the stock market,
arguably an event of
high economic importance
because people make a lot of
money, potentially, from it.
So there's this very nice
people by Huberman and Regev
from 2001 which has--
it's essentially an event
study and a case study
of stock market development
of a company called EntreMed.
And this company in 1997
on October, November
has very positive early
results on a cure for cancer.
Now, for any of these
types of companies,
having new cures and new
medications or vaccines
or the like are hugely valuable
because they can sell a lot
of their product in the future,
which means, essentially,
positive news about that
means you'll have lots--
at least with high probability
or higher probability--
large profits in the
future, to the extent
that the stock market is
an indication of that.
You might expect the
stock market to go up.
Now then, November 28,
the journal Nature,
which was a very highly
prominent scientific journal,
features this new
very prominently.
And The New York Times,
in fact, reports on it
on page A28, which is very
much in the back of the paper.
And on May 3, this is a
whole six months later.
The New York Times
again features
essentially the same story as on
November 28 on the front page.
OK.
Now, then on November 12, 1998,
the Wall Street Journal front
page then reports about
a failed replication.
It's essentially
to say, well, these
are promising new early results.
These early results are
often small samples.
And it's not quite clear,
does it replicate really
with larger samples and so on.
Is this really a good cure?
And so you kind of
won't have replications.
And really, only if you're
able to replicate your results
is this actually
something that's useful
and that you can make money off.
Now, what happened to the
EntreMed stock prices?
And so the first
question you might
say is, well, in a
world of full attention
with unlimited arbitrage,
as in if people
took full advantage of the
news and reacted perfectly,
what would we expect?
And second, in reality,
what did actually happen?
So let's first ask the
first question about,
with full attention,
what would we expect?
I guess there's a bit
of a question what
happens in the first one.
There's a bit of a question,
is there insider trading?
Or who gets the news
in the first place?
So one thing you might say is,
well, maybe the first one, only
the company knows.
And maybe that's not
public knowledge.
And then if there's
insider trading,
maybe the stock
market might go up.
But surely, like in number
two, if Nature prominently
features it, there's going
to be a bunch of traders,
a bunch of people who invest
in this company or not.
If they pay attention,
they should really
know what's going on,
and they should really--
the stock market should go up.
Conditional on that, on the
November 28 news, on May 3,
there's really no
news here, right?
It's kind of like
we knew this before.
If everybody was paying
attention before carefully,
the stock market should
have incorporated.
The news is out.
Traders know.
You should buy this, or
stocks at this company
is going to be more profitable.
So stocks should go up.
So really, if there's
full attention,
you expect nothing to
happen on May 3, '98.
And then if there's a
failed replication, well,
to the extent that this means
this cancer cure is entirely
useless, the stock market
should essentially just go down
to where it was before.
Now, but what about in reality?
So let me actually
just show you.
So here's the reality of this.
So there's not even--
there's the previous
events done in here.
This is essentially the
first story that comes out.
You see a little bit
of an increase here.
But actually, quite a bit in
relative terms with something
like 5%.
It seems like people
just didn't really quite
notice what was going on.
And there's also
no trend upwards.
It's not like the news is
spreading across people and so
on.
And then there's like a huge
jump now in The New York Times,
right?
So this is essentially here,
it's in The New York Times
but in the back of the journal.
Up here, it's essentially The
New York Times, the front page.
And suddenly, lots of
people pay attention
to news that's actually not
news because that was already
in The New York Times before.
To the extent that
everybody pays attention
to this, unlimited attention
and unlimited arbitrage,
we should essentially expect
no effects whatsoever.
So we see a huge spike in
the stock market price.
Maybe the stock market
overreacted a bit
and went down a little bit.
But then what we see here is
then the negative effective
of the failed replication.
Notice that here, the stock
market is still quite a bit
high.
The price is still up quite a
bit high, maybe twice as high,
about 20 compared to
10 as it was before.
It's a little bit hard to
interpret that because it could
just be that maybe
there's still a chance
that the cure might work out.
Maybe there's other news about
the company in the meantime
that are positive and so on.
But the key part
here is the fact
that the stock market went
up here on May 4, 1998,
really is saying it's
news for lots of people.
And really, it
shouldn't be news.
And there shouldn't
be any reaction
because, essentially,
it's old news,
as you would say, in the
sense of people in 1997
in November 28 already
reported all of that.
Does that make sense?
OK.
And there's lots of examples
of these kinds of things.
But essentially,
some of this is--
in attention, some of
it is also confusion.
I don't know if any
of you have heard
of what happened to the
Zoom stock market price,
stock price.
I don't know if any of you
have heard of this story.
So essentially,
there's a company Zoom,
which is the company
that we're using
right now to record this video.
The stock market
price of Zoom has
gone up a lot during
the last three months,
rightly so because
Zoom now has--
Zoom's profits
has gone up a lot.
For example, MIT now
has a corporate license
of Zoom, which essentially
means thousands of people
now are using or can use Zoom,
and that's an expensive thing
to do.
It turns out there's
another company that's
also called Zoom except for
that it's a different company
and has nothing to do with
the actual Zoom technology.
It turns out that
the Zoom stock market
price for this other company
went up a lot, as well.
The ticker for that company is
actually ZOOM, so like Zoom,
as opposed to the
actual Zoom company
that we're using right now.
Their ticker is ZM.
And so at some point,
actually, the trading
for that other company
was halted, presumably
because people
were very confused,
and they were not really
paying close attention
to what is the right ticker,
what's the right company
that they're actually buying.
They thought they
were buying Zoom,
like the actual online
video conferencing
company, while in
fact they were just
buying some other company
that's actually not
even doing anything anymore.
So there's lots of stories
about people being inattentive
even in situations when stakes
are really, really high.
Now, then, you might say,
well, how do we now measure?
So now in some sense we
have some evidence here
that people are-- in some sense
somewhat informal evidence
that people are inattentive.
Now, how would you measure the
impact of inattention overall?
So if you wanted to just
measure and demonstrate
that people are inattentive,
in addition to what I've just
shown you, what might you do?
How might you do that?
There's some information that
you usually get in the world
and they should have.
One example that we can discuss
is essentially prices or taxes.
And now if you want to
demonstrate that people
are actually missing those
prices or taxes, what
you can do is now you
can make it very salient.
You make it really
apparent to people.
And then you can look at, when
you look at changes in prices
or the change of making things
from non-selling to selling,
how do people react?
Or maybe you make, for
example, taxes very salient.
What happens to people's
demand for certain products?
And if then making things
salient changes people's
behavior, that then identifies
underlying inattention.
So if you just-- people
don't have access
to certain information,
in some sense, that's
less interesting
because that just means,
well, I don't have
the information
that's really available to me.
But in some ways, I
could make information
that's really very salient--
I essentially could
reduce the salience,
as you say, of certain types
of information-- again,
information that should
be available to them.
For example, suppose I do sales.
And I'm trying to, as
a company, sell things.
You go to a store.
And usually, sales are made
very salient to people.
Now you could essentially
just change the prices
without making these
sales very salient.
And then you could look at, how
attentive are people to that?
In a way, that's, in some
ways, less natural, right,
because when people are--
in a way, what we
want to demonstrate
is that in people's
real lives, there's
information available to them.
And they're not really paying
sufficiently much attention
to it.
So if you can then
change that in some ways
and demonstrate that now
they're changing their behavior,
that must mean that
previously, they
had been like misoptimizing.
If instead you
did something like
if you reduce the salience of
certain types of information,
that's, in a way, somewhat less
interesting because it would
say, well, it doesn't
really mean that they
were inattentive to start with.
It's more like you're hiding
something from people,
and now they can't find it.
That's, in some ways,
somewhat less interesting.
But I think in principle,
you'd also, exactly as you say,
identify inattention.
So there's a few type of
things that people have done.
And to be clear, there's
often a pretty fine line
between attention and memory.
So one thing we could do is--
and this is what Maya was
saying previously--
you could make certain features,
like taxes, very salient.
That's what we're
going to look at next.
In addition, you could
provide some information
when the correct response
is known already.
That's one we're going
to talk about afterwards
is the study by Hanna et al.
So that's kind of
like when people
have certain types of
information already
but then providing that
information again or giving
that information in some
sort of concise form
and potentially notifying
people of the fact
that this information could
be or should be important.
And then we now see
people react to it.
That doesn't mean that that
must mean that, before, they
were inattentive.
Another thing that people
have done a lot is reminders.
Reminders often
are sort of like--
you can think of the
pieces like memory issues,
and people just forget things.
But in some sense, memory
issues and attention issues
are very closely linked.
If you forget
something, then you
don't pay attention
to something.
So if I remind you of
something, now you're
paying attention
to, for example,
your savings or your medical
adherence, like you should
take certain drugs and so on.
There's a number of studies that
essentially provide reminders
to people.
And if these reminders
have effects,
then that must mean that people
were not paying attention
to those kinds of
things, often presumably
because of memory problems.
They just forget sometimes.
OK.
So now let me start
with a very simple model
to help us understand the
results from the Chetty et al.
paper.
It's very simple and very
sort of just sketched.
But I think it's
actually helpful to see
what people are doing.
So consider a good
with a value of V
inclusive of the price, which
is the sum of two components.
The components are
little v and o.
So there's visible and
salient component v,
and there's an
opaque component o.
OK.
And so if you're
now inattentive,
the consumer, inattentive
consumer perceived
value-- instead of
perceiving the true value V,
the consumer perceives
the value of V hat,
which is little v, which
is a salient component.
So even if you're
inattentive, the assumption
is the salient part of
the good you always see.
For example, what color
is the good or the like?
You always see that.
And in addition, the opaque
component, the stuff that's
not salient, you're only
going to pay attention
to the fraction
of 1 minus theta.
So the degree of
inattention-- so theta
is our inattention parameter.
And theta measures how much
are you paying attention
to stuff that's not
particularly salient.
So for theta equals 0, you're
back to the cases before.
For theta equals 0, V hat
equals V, which is essentially
just a standard case.
If theta were 1-- so theta is
supposed to be between 0 and 1.
If theta is 1, then
essentially you're
not paying attention at all
to the opaque component.
And anywhere in between,
essentially, then, you're
paying only partial attention
to the opaque component.
So the interpretation is each
individual essentially sees v--
sorry, sees o to some degree
but processes it only partially
to the degree of theta.
Of course, whether you actually
see it and not process it
or whether you miss it
entirely is, in some sense,
a philosophical question.
But think about like, everybody
has, at least in principle,
access to the component o.
But they only process
and pay attention to it
only to some degree.
OK.
So Chetty et al. applies this
model essentially to taxes.
So one very interesting
feature about some taxes
is the fact that sales taxes
are only added at the register,
right?
At least in most cases, you
would shop in the store.
And then the sales tax, only
at the end once you actually
go to the store, will be added.
Now, people are not--
people know.
When you ask people
directly, what
is the sales tax in your state,
people actually on average
are pretty good at knowing this.
So it's not like people don't
know that there's a sales tax.
But they might just
forget that there
are sales taxes for goods.
So now what you can do now
is you can compare the demand
response to sales tax changes
versus the demand response
to other price changes, right?
So if you see prices
fluctuating in a store over time
or across goods,
presumably, everybody
sees those price
changes overall,
if these are price
changes that are not
related to sales
taxes, the reason
being once you're in the store,
you're going to look at prices.
You're going to see is
the price high or low
even before you go
to the register.
So presumably, you see the
price tag pretty much most
of the time.
In contrast, when you
look at sales tax changes,
if the sales taxes
go up for some reason
or if there's a sales tax
for some items versus others,
you might just miss
that at the time
when you're choosing your goods
before you go to the register.
And once you're then
at the register,
you might not even notice that
you have paid the sales tax.
Or you might be
surprised and just don't
change your behavior any
more but at least notice it.
So now what did
Chetty et al. do?
They have data on the demand
for items in a grocery store.
And they have essentially
the demand, D of V hat.
Remember, V hat is the function
of the perceived value,
which I showed you here before.
Let me go back for a second.
So you see V hat
here is v, which
is the salient component,
plus 1 minus theta times o
as the opaque component.
So the demand for goods depends
on the perceived value, V hat,
that people have.
And there's a visible
part as the value V, which
is inclusive of the price.
So when you look at
when you're in a store,
you look at the good.
You see the good.
You see whether you like it.
You see the brand.
You see the color and
so on and so forth.
You also see the
price, so the valuation
that you give or the value
V that you draw from that
is essentially telling
how much they want
to have this thing minus
the price that you see,
which goes into the visible
part of your valuation.
And then there's a
less visible part,
which is just stuff
that's essentially hidden.
And there's a bunch of
different parts to that
that you might not
pay attention to,
which could be
ingredients or the like,
or was it organic
or not and the like.
But in particular,
the sales tax, right?
So if you think
about your valuation,
you would have to
essentially, however
much you like the
good-- you have
to subtract the
sales tax because you
have to pay taxes on that good.
And that's less
visible to some people.
So you might not
pay attention to it.
So in this case, it'll be V hat
is v, the visible component,
plus 1 minus theta times o.
And that's just repeating
what I showed you before.
And that equals v minus
1 minus theta times tp,
which is the sales tax.
And now to the extent that
people pay attention to theta,
the sales tax might
matter more or less.
There might be other
opaque components
that are unobservable
both to the experimenter
but also to the person.
They can abstract from that.
So for now, they can essentially
say the less visible part
is only the state tax.
OK.
Any questions on this?
So now, and this
is sort of like--
so now, essentially,
what this gives us now,
we can essentially try
to see if we have this--
how can we identify
this parameter theta
by making things very salient?
And so the idea is now to
make the tax fully salient.
Let me show you how this
looks like in practice.
Here's the math.
But I'll go back to
this in a second.
Let me just show you what this
looks like in the experiment.
So the idea in the
experiment is to say--
you see on the lower part
here, you see a normal price.
You see an original
price tag here.
This is what the price tag
usually would look like.
So this would be an item.
I guess this is brushes.
This item would
cost $5.79 usually.
And then what they
did in the experiment,
they essentially added a tag
where they said, now here,
%5.79 plus sales tax is $6.22.
And now they make
it entirely salient
that there's a sales
tax, and you make
the true price very salient.
OK.
And now the question
is if you do
that, if we go from theta
being, for example, say 5.5,
you only partially
observe the sales tax.
If you go from that to making
the sales tax fully salient,
what happens to people's demand?
And can you infer from that
theta, what theta actually
looks like?
So let me go back to this.
So essentially, what
we're trying to look at,
we're trying to look
at a change in demand
when theta falls to 0.
Why does theta fall to 0?
The assumption here
is that whatever
is theta people have before,
so you might partially
or even not at all--
theta might be 0.5 or 1
or whatever for people.
But now the
intervention that I just
showed you brings
theta down to 0, right?
Because now it's fully
salient to people
what the sales tax is.
And so the question
is now, can we
have an expression for
the change in log demand
when theta falls from whatever
it is before down to 0?
So now what we have is
the change in log demand
is the demand that
we had before.
This is what I
showed you before.
This was essentially demand
as a function of V. Remember
what I showed you here before.
Give me one second.
I'll go back.
So what I showed you here,
demand is a function of V hat.
And V hat is this animal here.
It's v minus 1 minus
theta times tp.
Now, the question is, what
happens to demand when
or log demand here--
forget about the log.
It's not that interesting.
That's just for math.
So here's the demand as a
function of what it was before.
And here's demand
when I now make
things very salient, right?
So now here in this
case, theta equals 0.
And here, theta is
whatever it had before.
Now when you have
this expression, what
you can do is you can linearize
that, take the derivative
and say, what is
this difference?
Well, this difference is--
and you can do the math.
It's essentially theta times tp.
And then here, this
is the derivative
with respect to theta.
And what this gives
you essentially
is that the change in log
demand is a function of theta,
a function of tau,
which is like the tax,
and eta, which is
the price elasticity.
So essentially, that's to say
if you have now an intervention,
we can look at, how does
demand or log demand change
when we do this
intervention, assuming
that this intervention
brings theta from whatever
it was before down to 0?
We can look at now
what happens to demand.
That's delta log demand here.
That's just a definition.
And you can have that.
That's an expression of how we
can relate that to theta to t,
which is like the taxes--
it is at something like 7%--
and then eta, which is the
price elasticity of demand.
So that is to say, if we have
this change in demand that we
observe from changing
theta down to 0
and if we had the price
elasticity from just
other variation in prices
that we see in the world
and if you have t, which is
just how much the tax is,
that would allow us
to identify theta.
And that's what the
experiment is trying to do.
So that implies essentially--
so we can just rearrange this.
We can just say theta is, just
sort of rearranging things,
minus the change in log demand
from this intervention divided
by t times the price elasticity.
OK, and that is just
to say essentially
what we're trying to see is,
intuitively, that's just to say
once we make things very salient
going from things not being
salient to start with to
making things very salient,
how much does
demand change there?
And then we can
look at, well, for--
in this case, I guess, this is
the taxes made very salient.
And then we can
look at, well, how
does this compare
to other changes
in prices, assuming that
essentially people are paying
attention to prices anyway?
So if you look at things
becoming more expensive by 1%,
how much are people changing
their behavior there?
And now we have to take into
account that what's being
made salient here is the tax t.
And from backing out the
relative changes in demand
for usual price changes
versus making things salient,
we can now try to measure
theta as how much did they
pay attention before.
So one way to say this is for
example, if we make things very
salient and the
change in log demand
did not-- there's no
change in log demand,
what does that imply for theta?
What would we learn from that?
So what was the change
here in demand at 0?
People did not change
the demand at all
when you make
things very salient
versus what it was before.
Or put differently, if
theta equals 0 here,
then these two expressions are
the same, which essentially
means that this thing here
is also going to be 0.
So essentially, to the extent
that our intervention induces
large changes in demand, that
must mean that essentially,
people were very
attentive to start with.
Essentially, if I'm making
the prices very salient
and nothing happens, well,
that means people were already
paying attention before.
Now, in the maximum
case, if people
were paying no attention
to prices before,
what would happen then?
Well, in that case, I
guess-- oops, sorry.
In that case, theta would be 1.
So essentially, it
would just be going
from-- we would look at what's
the demand or change in demand
from going v minus tp to
v, which is essentially
just a change in tp.
So that would be essentially
say if the tax was 7%, now
we just have to look at
what is the equivalent
effect of a 7% increase
in the price, which
is exactly what we have here.
So essentially,
just to summarize--
and I think the math is, in some
sense, not that interesting.
But essentially,
to summarize, it's
like the larger our reaction
is to this intervention,
the more inattentive
most people have
been before because if they're
inattentive to start with,
they react more to making
things more salient.
So let me show you what
this looks like in practice.
Again, the goal here is to
estimate a change in demand
from making taxes fully salient.
Again, here's the
original tag, and here's
the experimental tag.
It's very, very salient, very,
very clear, and very hard
to miss for people.
And the assumption
essentially is
that people pay now full
attention to this new tag.
They have a three-week
period in which--
and this is an
experiment in California.
They have a three-week
period in which
they modify price
tags of certain items
so that they go essentially
to different stores.
They pick one store.
And then essentially,
they modify the price tag
only of the subset
of randomized goods.
And they make the after-tax
price salient in addition
to the pre-tax price, right?
The pre-tax price is
already very salient here.
In addition, they make the
after-tax price very salient.
And now they're
going to do what's
called a triple-diff estimate,
which is, in some sense, a very
funky or fancy word just to
say what we're going to do
is we compare the
sales or the demand
during the treatment
periods to the following.
So there's a treatment period.
We compare how much of certain
goods have been treated.
How much do the sales change
compared to the previous week
sales for the same items?
Second, we're going
to compare them
to sales for items in which
the tax was not made salient.
So there's some goods in the
store for which the tax was not
made salient.
And then finally, there's
going to be control stores.
So we're going to
look at essentially,
in the stores that
receive the treatment
or in the store that receives
the treatment, what happens
to the goods that receive
the treatment compared
to the goods that don't
receive the treatment?
We compare that to demand
before the treatment was
enacted for both of
those types of goods.
Essentially, what's
the relative change
in demand for the treated versus
the non-treated items before
versus after?
So that's essentially
what people
would call a diff in diff,
like difference in differences.
And in addition to that,
they compare that difference
in differences to the same
difference in differences
in the control stores.
So let me show you exactly
what this looks like.
So this is a bit
of a messy table
or a table with a
lot of information.
But it's in fact quite simple.
So what we have here is at
the top is a treatment store.
And at the bottom, there's
some control stores.
So in the control stores,
nothing has been changed.
So there's no experiment.
There's no additional tax
and so on being added.
In the treatment stores, there's
going to be control categories
and treated categories.
Notice that they didn't fully
randomize all the goods.
So it's not like if there's
one brush next to another,
one brush has taxes versus not.
Presumably, because they're
trying to minimize spillovers
in some sense, if you only
make this tax salient for one
good that's next
to another good,
people would get very confused
because they're like, well,
why does this one have
taxes made salient and then
the other one not?
So now this is across
categories where people maybe
only pay attention to certain
goods in certain categories
to start with.
So what we're seeing
here is now here,
these are the control categories
and the treated categories.
And we can look at what's called
the difference in differences.
We can look at the change in
demand in the treatment stores.
What we're going to
look at is essentially
the change in demand in
the control categories
and the treatment categories.
So what we see here
is we can compare
how much is sold in the
experimental period, which
is this row here,
compared to our baseline.
What we see is essentially
demand in the control
categories was going up
a little bit by 0.84.
That's just because
of seasonalities.
Maybe people were just
buying more anyway
for whatever reason.
And in the treated categories
over the same period,
comparing essentially
the experimental periods
to the baseline period,
demand went down.
So now the difference
in differences estimate
is essentially the change in
demand in the treatment stores,
comparing the treated categories
compared to the control
categories, which is
just the difference
between this column
and this column,
which is minus 2.14 units.
OK.
So that's essentially,
how much did the demand
change before versus after in
the treated categories compared
to the same change in
the control categories?
So that's essentially
a difference
in differences estimator.
Now, they also have
the control stores.
Why would we want the
control stores, as well?
Why is that helpful to have?
Suppose that improved sunscreen,
and now it's getting warmer.
It's really hot, and everybody
was out buying sunscreen.
Then you see essentially
people's demand
in the control categories.
The treatment category
goes up by a lot
or goes down by a lot
for whatever reason.
Suppose it's umbrellas, and
one week was really rainy,
and the other one was not rainy.
And we see now essentially
seasonal or other differences
over time in some of the
categories that would,
even if it's randomized,
it could just
happen to be the case.
So that would not have to
do anything with a sales tax
being salient.
That's just by chance.
So now it's very nice to
have some control stores
where we can look at like the
same difference in difference
estimates and some of the
control stores, in some sense,
like a placebo.
They can do the same things.
There's going to be the control
categories and the treatment
categories.
Notice, to be very clear,
in the control stores,
the treated categories do not
receive any actual treatment.
So we can do the same
difference in differences.
And what we see here is now
that there's essentially
no difference here.
So the demand in the
control categories
went up a little bit for
whatever reason in the treated.
And this is a little bit smaller
than in this other store.
This difference is not
statistically significant.
But anyway, the control
categories go up a little bit.
The treated categories
go also up a little bit.
When you do this difference
in differences estimate,
you find essentially
no difference.
In the control
categories, there's
no change in the
treated categories
compared to the baseline
compared to the control
categories.
So difference in difference
estimate in the control
category is essentially 0.
And now what you can do is
essentially the difference
in differences estimate.
You can compare.
You can subtract
this number here
minus this number
here, which gives you
the triple-diff estimate,
which essentially
is the relative change of
treatment versus control
before and after and treatment
versus control stores.
It's a little bit lots of
differences in your head.
But I hope this comparison
from the table makes it clear.
Any questions on the
estimate or the procedure
that they're doing?
OK.
So what we see here now
is essentially now making
these taxes salient in
the treated categories
in the treatment stores
reduces demand, right?
Because essentially,
demand goes down.
Why does the demand go down?
Well, the perceived price that
people face has now gone up.
And now they buy
less of these goods,
presumably because before,
they were not paying attention.
Now the price goes up.
And now, essentially,
demand falls, as it should,
because now things
are more expensive.
And this is here the result. The
average quantity sold decreases
by 2.2 units-- this is
units of the goods--
relative to baseline
level of 25.
That's an 8.8% decline.
And now we can use
our own formula
and compute the
degree of inattention.
Essentially, now we can say, OK,
now we know what the tax was.
The tax was 7.375%.
We can estimate the price
elasticity in some other ways.
Essentially, we can say,
what happens if prices go up
by 1% for other reasons?
What if the salient component
that's already salient goes up?
This is week-by-week
variation across stores.
So if the prices go up,
what's the price elasticity?
And the estimate of
those price elasticity
is also given from
other variation.
That's 1.59.
And now we can essentially
back out theta.
Essentially, what
we're trying to ask
is we have a change in 2.2 units
that is making prices salient.
Now the question is, well,
how large of a change
is it relative to a change in
prices of 1%, 2%, and so on?
We know that essentially the
price elasticity is 1.59.
So we can essentially
just back out theta.
And so what we get
from this formula
now is that theta is about 0.75,
which says that consumers react
to price changes due to sales
tax changes only a quarter as
much as to other price changes.
So essentially, consumers are
very inattentive, in fact,
to sales taxes, to
sales tax changes.
In fact, they only
perceive a quarter
as much as any other price
changes in the world.
And that's really saying,
look, people really
seem to be missing these
things that are not salient.
Now if you make them salient,
people change their behavior.
Therefore, they must have been
inattentive to start with.
In addition to that
kind of evidence,
Chetty et al. also
have some evidence
on using non-experimental
variation.
And in some sense, you
could say the evidence
that I just showed you from
the store is a little bit
weird because, in some sense,
you see these different tags.
And maybe the tags
raise attention
to the price even
regardless of the tax.
And it's a little bit
weird in some ways.
So it's quite nice to have
some complementary evidence
of a non-experimental
panel deliberation.
And so what they do is they
look at beer consumption.
And it turns out beer, tobacco,
and other types of goods
have two types of
taxes levied on them.
They have an excise tax, which
is included in the price.
This is highly salient
during choice the process
because essentially it's
in the price already.
So if taxes go up,
essentially, the price goes up.
And people will notice
if they pay attention
or since they pay attention
to prices, since they
like the price tag already.
And then there's a sales tax.
This is the tax that we were
just talking about before.
That's essentially very opaque
during the choice process,
as we just showed.
And now we can look at
variation across states
and over time of changes in
excise taxes and sales taxes.
And we can look at,
how much do people
react to excise taxes
relative to how much people
react to sales taxes.
And that relative reaction
will tell us, again,
something about theta.
And what Chetty et al. finds
in here is a table for that.
Essentially, when you look
at changes in excise taxes,
this tax is very salient.
The price elasticity
is above 0.8 or 0.9.
So essentially, when
the price goes up by 1%,
people react by about almost 1%.
In contrast, there's some
differences in estimates.
But once you control
for things properly,
people essentially do not
react to the sales tax at all.
Maybe a little bit, but overall,
the number's very, very low.
And now, essentially, the ratio
of these types of reaction
tells you how
attentive people are.
Essentially, if you
divide, say, for example--
if you took column number three,
if you divide 0.003 by 0.86,
and you have to do a little
bit of additional math
that's uninteresting--
you essentially
will get a result that,
essentially, people do not
pay attention to sales taxes.
1 minus theta is
eventually close to 0.
Put differently, the degree
of inattention is almost 1.
Theta is almost 1.
So essentially, people
do not pay attention
to these types of taxes.
Inattention is almost complete.
So there's substantial
consumer inattention
to non-transparent taxes.
So what I've shown you
so far is, essentially,
the existence of inattention.
It doesn't say why
people are inattentive.
It could be people just can't
do the math in their head.
It could be people don't
want to bother with it.
They're sort of saying, well,
it's kind of a small change.
So why do we really care?
It could be that people who
buy alcohol half of the time
are drunk, and they
don't pay any attention.
There's no modeling in any way
of, why are people doing this?
This is just saying this shows
the existence of inattention
in those kinds of
consumer choices.
It doesn't say why
people are inattentive.
And you might say,
well, 7% of a tax
is kind of a small distortion.
So it might be actually
optimal to miss that,
which is a reasonable approach.
It is probably
quite a bit of money
and quite a bit of
distortion if you think
about it and you actually--
7% is not nothing.
But if you have a
lot of money anyway,
you might as well just not pay
any attention to that stuff
and if that helps you pay
attention to other things.
Notice that even
then, that shows
the existence of inattention.
It's just a bit of
a question, like,
how important is inattention?
And this actually gets
me to the next point,
which is a question
of, why should we care
about inattention to taxes?
Why is that important or
interesting potentially?
Question exactly is,
who's paying attention?
Who's not paying attention?
And then who's
sort of distorting
their behavior potentially?
There's lots of interesting
issues about heterogeneity
and who's paying attention.
Let me talk about
this in a second.
Let me ask differently.
Why is it that some taxes, the
excise taxes, are very salient?
And why is it that other
taxes are not salient?
What do you think about that?
Is that an accident?
Or why is it that the taxes
for alcohol and tobacco,
et cetera, are very salient?
And why is it that other
taxes for shampoo or
whatever are
actually not salient?
There's two simple objectives
if you took a public economics
class, if you took
John Gruber's class,
but also if you
took 1401 or 1403.
The reason why the
government levies taxes is--
one big reason is to
generate revenue, right?
The government needs money.
Somehow, we need to tax people.
And the issue, of course,
is that if you levy taxes
on some goods
versus others, that
can distort consumer choices.
And there's essentially
some theorems
and some considerations about
which goods should you tax.
And ideally, you would
tax goods that people
are consuming anyway.
Essentially, what you
want is people make--
so essentially, when you
have taxes on some goods
but not on others, if
people have different price
elasticities on some
goods versus others
and if you increase one good or
all goods by a certain amount,
if people have different
price elasticities,
then you might distort
their behavior.
So if you increase and you
start taxing one thing and not
another, people might
shift to the other good.
And we don't want that because,
presumably, people are already
optimizing to start with.
Now, if people are
inelastic to certain goods,
if people need
certain goods anyway
and they buy them anyway--
and the last thing, essentially,
there's public goods.
Public economics would tell you
or some theories would tell you
you should tax these goods more.
Now, distortion, when people
are-- so the distortions
are lower if people don't
fully react to taxes.
That could be if, for example,
you started taxing bread,
for example, while everybody--
or certain goods like potatoes,
where everybody needs to
buy these goods anyway
because people need to eat--
well, then, there
would be very low--
these goods would
be very inelastic.
And that's because
they need those things.
Not because they're
inattentive, but just
because they need
these types of goods.
Now, there's obviously
issues with poverty.
We don't want to tax
the poor too much.
But in general, they want to
tax things that are inelastic.
And so in a way, if people
are inattentive to the taxes,
in a way, that's great
because now they're
not distorting their behavior.
And we can still
get money from them.
So in some sense, actually,
some of the inattention
for that purpose
might be actually good
because now people are not
distorting their behavior
by looking at those prices.
So being inattentive
in some ways is good.
But exactly as Maya was
saying, for some goods--
and these are often labeled
as sin goods or the like,
where there's either
externalities or internalities.
For example, if you think
about tobacco or alcohol,
there are externalities.
Tobacco, for example, secondhand
smoking is bad for others.
For alcohol, there's
often externalities
in terms of drunk driving
or violence or the like.
So the government wants to
increase the price of alcohol
because when people are making
choices of how much alcohol
to buy, they might not take into
account the effects of alcohol
on others.
By internalities, I mean
people might not necessarily
take into account the
effect of alcohol or tobacco
on themselves.
This is what we
discussed previously.
This could be because
of present bias.
This could be because of
biased beliefs or the like.
Essentially, people might
hurt their future selves.
And the government
might say, well,
let's increase taxes
because their future sales--
people might like
that there might
be a way of helping
people, for instance,
deal with self control problems.
So here, the
government explicitly
wants consumers to
react to the taxes.
The point is not to
make money from people.
And in fact, sometimes
you're worried
about making too much
money from people.
The point here is really
to change behavior
to reduce the behaviors
that are being taxed.
So you want to make such
taxes particularly salient.
Ready?
Now, look at the taxes on
alcohol versus the taxes on--
some of the excise taxes
versus the sales taxes.
The excise taxes are
precisely salient because we
want people to react to it
while the sales taxes are not.
Of course, there's
variation across places.
But it's not an accident that
we see this in the world the way
that is.
Now, one thing that's
quite interesting now is--
and I think Jos or
[INAUDIBLE] was saying that.
It's like when consumers
are heterogeneous,
then there's a lot of
quite interesting issues.
For example, if you have
the poor paying more or less
attention compared to the rich
or if only a subset of people
pay attention to those
goods, then in a way,
you would find that the average
elasticity is still quite low.
But some people are actually
distorting their behavior
quite a bit, and others do not.
And that gets relatively
quickly quite complicated.
And you could then
get into situations
where you make some people a
lot worse off and some people
better off when making
something salient versus not.
Any questions on all of this?
OK.
So then we get to
the next question.
This is getting a little
bit at the question that
was asked previously about,
can inattention or attention
have large effects?
And so on the one hand,
you might say, well,
people's choices-- for
example, consumption patterns--
are distorted due to
limited attention.
But you might ask, well,
if it's really true
that people's consumption
patterns have really distorted
that much, if I'm so much worse
off by not paying attention
to things, well, eventually,
I'm going to notice this.
Somebody is going to tell me.
Or in a way, I notice
myself eventually
that I'm doing things really
worse compared to my friends.
And eventually, if things
are really distorted a lot,
I might pay attention to it.
So the underlying idea is
that, potentially, people
are actually inattentive
in the sense of saying,
look, people's attention
is limited in some ways.
But it's optimal for
people to pay attention
to things that are
really important.
And there, the
underlying question
is, what is salient to people?
And how do people
decide what to focus on?
And won't people pay
attention to important things
anyway if they have to?
And so then the
question is, well,
how is it possible
that inattention could
have large effects anyway?
And so the next paper is
a good example of that.
And here's a very intuitive
example of why that might be.
So consider the
following situation.
You have been getting headaches.
You go to the doctor.
And the doctor asks you
whether it gets worse
after eating certain foods.
And so what are
you going to say?
Well, the answer will probably
be like, I don't know.
And why is that?
Why might you just not even know
the answer to that question?
An underlying
theory in your mind
of why you might be
getting headaches.
And you might just
not have a theory
that it's related to
your food consumption.
So while you have lots
of data in front of you--
you eat every day, you
get headaches on some days
and not on others-- you could
surely pay attention to it
if you wanted to.
But it's not even a
theory in your mind,
so you won't even encode
the relevant information
if you don't expect to have
food allergies or gluten
allergy or the like
if you don't expect
that to be a likely cause.
Then you're never going
to actually pay attention,
and you get infinite amounts of
data on every day and headaches
and food consumption.
But you're never going
to notice because you
don't have a theory in your mind
that that might be the case.
And so there's a relationship
between attention and memory.
You only remember or pay
attention to stuff that
actually are theories of yours.
And then you'll
remember those things
that you actually paid
attention to in the first place.
And so selective
attention, then,
may have persistent
effects on what we learn.
Essentially, you could
have unlimited amounts
of information in front of you.
And you will never
learn because you never
just had it on your radar that
this information is actually
relevant for the issue at hand.
And Josh Schwartzstein
has a very nice model
that illustrates that.
Another example
is from medicine.
Many women died
from childbed fever
at hospitals in the
mid-19th century.
The popular theories
were bad smells
at the hospital, presence
of male doctors wounded
the modesty of the mothers.
That's, of course, nonsense.
The true explanation is germs.
Doctors didn't wash their hands.
And again, it's something--
that's not a tricky thing
to figure out if you
have the idea, if you
have the hypothesis or the idea
that this could be important.
And presumably, some doctors
are washing their hands anyway
and sometimes are not, and they
would have a lot fewer deaths.
But nobody was noticing
because, again, just nobody
was paying attention.
So once you have the
right theory in mind,
then you can test it.
And then, of course, you can
gather the right information
and pay attention to the
right information and learn.
Now, the basic model from
Josh Schwartzstein-- beliefs
today matter for what
is being attended
to today, which then affect
people's beliefs tomorrow.
And now if you don't
attend to the right things,
if your model of the
world is the wrong model,
you might never learn to
attend to important aspects
of the world.
And so then
forecasts and beliefs
may be biased and persistently
biased in a systematic fashion.
And you might persistently
misreact and misattribute
causes to unimportant variables
because you have never
even considered the idea of
the correct model of the world.
And so now the paper
I'm going to show
you is an example of that.
This is seaweed
farming in Indonesia,
which is not immediately
obvious why that's related.
But I'll show you in a second.
So this is what seaweed
farming looks like.
I'll give you this
relatively briefly.
But essentially, it's
like, at some beaches,
you can grow seaweeds
in these rows.
And you see these
round things here,
which are essentially pods.
And so there are
many factors that are
important in seaweed farming.
Essentially, it's like these
pods, which are essentially
these round things
that you see here,
they're essentially
grown in different lines.
And so if you're
seaweed farmers,
what's really important
is line spacing--
or potentially important is line
spacing, pod spacing, and pod
size, how we got these pods.
Now, how does seaweed
farming actually work?
I've never done
seaweed farming myself,
but apparently this
is how it works.
So farmers use what's called
the bottom method, which
is they drive wooden stakes
in shallow bottom near shore,
and they attach lines
to these stakes.
And they take raw seaweed
from the last harvest
and cut it into pods, like
these kind of roundish things.
And the pods are planted
by attaching them
at a given interval on
the line from the sea.
And at low tides,
farmers tend the plots.
And so the seaweed is then
harvested after 30 to 40 days.
And so now many dimensions
could matter-- the pod size,
the distance between the lines,
the distance between pods,
timing, and so on.
One nice thing about seaweed
is there's many different pods.
You can actually try
and learn and estimate
the importance of
these factors over time
if only you paid attention.
But the question is, which of
these factors are important?
And are people paying
attention to those factors?
And so what the
experiment now is doing
is there's lots of farmers
in the experiment that
are quite experienced.
They have been doing this for a
long time, 18 years of farming.
Many of them or the vast
majority are literate.
So these are people
who should really
know what they're doing in their
seaweed farming experience.
And so the enumerators
went to visit these farmers
and to measure and document
their farming methods.
And when you asked them
about current pod size,
you just ask them how
big are your pods,
people just don't
know the answer to.
They also don't
know the answer to,
what's the optimum pod size?
When you just ask them how
big are your pods when you
plant them, they don't know.
When you ask them what's
the best way to do it,
they don't know.
Importantly, they know exactly
the answer to other questions.
They know the length
of the typical line.
They know the distance
between the lines.
And they also have
very clear ideas
of what's optimal to do so.
But they seem to essentially
neglect the pod size dimension
entirely when they're
thinking about what to do.
And so in the
experimental trial now,
they did essentially
different treatments.
And the treatments
were essentially such
that farmers were provided
experimental variation
in the different pod sizes
and essentially induced
to experiment with pod sizes.
And in some cases, farmers
were just left on their own.
They were just induced
to do this experiment.
And the question was
like, now will farmers
learn from their own
in this experiment?
And then in addition, they also
have an information condition
where they then summarized
that information to the farmers
in addition.
So the question is
now, once farmers
are induced to
experiment, you surely
would think that
farmers would learn now
that they're given all the
information that they need on,
like, here's the
different pod sizes.
Here's the different
profits that you
get from the different
types of pods.
Now they might
learn on their own.
But if you don't attend to
pod size in the first place,
if you think it's
irrelevant anyway,
even if you are induced
to do the experiment,
you're not going
to learn at all.
And so then they did essentially
these follow-up surveys.
And then we'll just skip.
So now what they do is they
also go through an information
provision where they essentially
tell farmers the [INAUDIBLE]
they were doing with everybody.
But in addition, they
also provided information
and did some simple
calculations on which
is the best combination
of pod size and distance.
Notice that farmers
are literate.
They're able to do
this on their own.
But the experiment was just
providing this information
to farmers explicitly
with a recommendation
about what's the pod weight and
what is the optimal distance.
And so now what the
experiment finds
is large gains from changing
the farming methodology.
And the trial
participation itself only
has an insignificant effect.
That's to say, in
addition, then,
summarized data for people
has much larger effect.
Essentially, focusing
people's attention to things
that they should already know
changes their farming behavior
a lot.
And it's essentially
evidence that people were not
paying attention
in the first place
even if you make them
participate in a trial
where they should have
really or could have,
at least, learned
things on their own.
There's large
impacts of the trial
if the data from the trials
is presented to farmers.
There's no impact of
the trial on dimensions
that farmers had already
noticed previously,
presumably because they're
already paying attention
and were optimizing.
So now what did we
learn from this?
And let me quickly
summarize and let you go.
So we have systematic
learning failures
even though all the
information was available.
So farmers simply
did not pay attention
because they didn't
think that pod size was
relevant in any
way in their lives.
And that's a
potential explanation
why people might
not pay attention
even to important information
because if your model
of the world is just
wrong, why would
you even think that
this is important?
And the problem here is then
there's never an opportunity
to actually learn.
You never even
collect information
that might reject your
model because you're
convinced that your model
is right in the first place.
And so then lack of attention
might generate arbitrarily
large welfare losses.
You can really screw up
big time for a long time
and never really change your
behavior because, essentially,
you never learn.
You never even pay
attention to any information
that you might have available
that says your model is wrong.